so many of the issues and challenges
that are being faced by the region today
I imagine would be solved by more rapid
economic growth certainly economic
growth it brings prosperity to people
and the question is how do we generate
that that economic growth I'm very
impressed at the energy in the region
and my belief strongly is that simply by
finding voice and sharing ideas this
region will skyrocket and we've already
begun to see that happen the youth are
finding their voice women are finding
their voice the bottom of the pyramid is
finding its voice people are lifting
themselves up and saying we're ready for
change and here are ideas that will move
us forward I think this region is poised
for greatness and I look forward to
seeing how immense events unfold in the
coming years